les autres deux ou trois autres gros
joueurs et je pense que vous avez dit ce
qu'elle est vraiment étroit quel était
leur proportion respect respectives donc
il y en a deux gros dans le secteur
souriante
est-ce que la vallée non moi j'aimerais
mieux que les noms soit pour avec votre
permission soit pas mentionnée par ces
gens là sont pas impliqués à ce stade si
je ne demanderai pas les noms que mais
je vous savoir leur participation autour
de 25%
il y en a un c'est 25% et l'autre plus
que monsieur accurso
oui l'autre ou peut-être 22 ou 23 mai et
espère ya et l'autre est à peu près et
ils tombaient plus calmes aussi donc est
trop important ou tourner deux premiers
autour de 20 pilotes est hauteur de 10
de ces trois joueurs ramasser et eux
seuls 50% du
des revenus de sonim désinvestissement
des investissements de la solution c'est
ça